here's former deputy treasury secretary
Roger Altman telling us flat out what we
are doing right now one thing that I'm
hearing from the treasury Department is
that this is not a bailout in their view
but for regular people it kind of looks
like one what do you think
well the term bailout is a obviously a
loaded one and it's in the eye of the
beholder you know it's it's like one
person's
one person to see something and to think
that the catastrophe another person sees
the same thing and thinks it's a small
accident
um but the main point here is that the
rescues of 2008 and 2009 which we all
remember so vividly
became ferociously unpopular I mean one
of the most unpopular things that the
federal government has done in 50 or 100
years many people think they led to
uh you know the growth of the tea party
and the the uh the growth of the Maga
movement and so forth
um and therefore the administration
today doesn't want to get within 100
miles of that term bailout now
uh
what the reg what the authorities did
over the weekend was absolutely profound
they guaranteed the deposits all of them
at Silicon Valley Bank and what that
really means
and they won't say this and I'll come
back to that
what that really means is that they have
guaranteed the entire deposit base of
the U.S financial system the entire
deposit base this is a breathtaking step
uh which effectively nationalizes or
federalizes the deposit base
of the U.S financial system now
uh you can call it a bailout you can
call it something else but it's it's
really absolutely profound now the
authorities including the White House
are not going to say that because what I
just said of course implies that they've
just nationalized the banking system
and then technically speaking they
haven't but in a broad sense they're
verging on that so look I would argue
this is exactly what the wokesters want
I can't really connect that directly to
Joe Biden because he's muddled and he's
not in charge but this is what they
would want right they like power and
control so what happened over the
weekend A Bank through incompetence and
then also all the nonsensical things
related to the government in terms of
inflation and everything else a bank
failed and instead of letting it fail
letting nature take its course and
saying sorry to the people that put your
money here we knew you know Silicon
Valley Bank was known to do risky
Investments if you're Silicon Valley
it's baked into the name of the thing
right these are these are speculative
companies these are often as I described
over the last couple days like as a guy
that started a tech company locals you
run at a deficit for a while as you're
getting investment but you're not
bringing in a ton of money the hope is
you will get enough users to see that
your product is valuable and then
eventually you'll figure out how to
monetize that but they were just pouring
money into these things and now we have
in essence as Altman is saying we have
nationalized these Banks and at this
point why wouldn't we nationalize them
all and you might go well why is that a
problem it's pretty good nobody lost
their money here well that sounds kind
of right but in woke World things that
sound right are usually very wrong
because once you have One Bank in
essence you will have one Bank the
United States government all the banks
there'll be no difference between any of
the banks there'll be no competition
there'll be no way that you can leverage
one against the other to get a better
rate and then we will all be in a very
calcified uh
system where there is no ability to get
a better deal
[Music]